but we're going to begin today with a
surprise development this is a big
surprise in the ahmad arbury trial the
defense called travis mcmichael to the
stand as its first witness now he is the
man who shot ahmad arbury to death back
in february of 2020. mcmichael is on
trial as you know along with his father
greg mcmichael and their neighbor
william roddy bryan the three men chased
arberry down while he was in the
neighborhood for a jog they claim they
were trying to make a citizen's arrest
omar villafranca is in brunswick georgia
where the trial is taking place omar
good morning a lot of people wanted to
hear what travis mcmichael had to say
good morning and it was surprising to
see him on the stand until yesterday the
only time we'd really seen him or heard
from him was in
are 911 police body cam video but
yesterday he decided to decline to
invoke his fifth amendment right and
tell his side of the story
sort of tell the truth whole truth to
nothing but the truth yes sir the first
witness for the defense was one of the
defendants
travis mcmichael testified that his
father told him to grab his gun before
chasing a mod arbory through the
neighborhood in what they claim was an
effort to make a citizen's arrest under
a now repealed georgia law did you want
to stop him and hold him so the police
could come and arrest him that was my
plan
mcmichael said he and his father
believed arbory was a burglar after
arbory had been seen at the construction
site of an unfinished home cell phone
video shows mcmichael confronting the
unarmed arbory after a prolonged chase
this is a life or death situation
and i'm going to have to
stop him from doing this so i shot
prosecutors argue there's no evidence
justifying the chase or the deadly
encounter and that there was never an
attempt to make a citizen's arrest the
homeowner larry english said arbory
never stole anything and that he never
asked mcmichaels to take action last
week the prosecution also called a
county police detective who read a
portion of his interview with greg
mcmichael hours after the shooting
he was trapped like a rat i think he was
wanting to flee
and he realized that something you know
he was not going to get away prosecutors
pushed mcmichael after he testified
about the law enforcement training he
received in the coast guard so you
learned as part of
your time in the military that
you can't force people to speak with you
that's correct you have to let them walk
away yes
arbory's mother wanda cooper jones spoke
outside the courthouse travis was on the
stand
wiping tears from his eyes but again
travis is alive
can you imagine the tears that we've
shared
the prosecution will continue their
cross-examination of mcmichael today the
judge is also expected to rule on
whether he'll allow evidence that
alleges that mcmichael used a racial
slur right after shooting arbory and
it's worth noting nate 12 jurors here on
this trial only one is black in a county
that is more than 25 percent
african-american
omar thank you so much